[Applaudissements]
nous
oui bras
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
hu
moi
c'est l'été en hiver et ça c'est nouveau
attachez vos lunettes préparer la
nuisette et galinette voici lunettes
noires pour nuits blanches
lardy show du samedi soir bonsoir lundi
à philips question qu'on monasterio
janice hahn dans les jambes dures etc
servi sur un plateau merci lui deuxième
légende du rock de la soirée encore un
plateau lui loue sans une ride
vous avez lu son clip il ya trois
semaines en exclu ce soir et l'atonie
childs l'ied l'ange gabriel trois
bouquins sous son aile bonsoir les
landes elle exclut sono mondiale 4
callaway repris par la jamaïque reggae
philharmonic orchestra le petit brun du
grand bleu eric sera-t-il le plus fort
blind test et voici franco battiato le
fameux violoniste ou italiano cas bravo
être secrétaire général des programmes
d'antenne de ses atouts c'est dan louis
blériot a exclu wells il ya un troisième
clip troisième tube pour toutes les
boîtes le yade
françois le garçon boucher va-t-il
dépecer riton érudit roth premier choix
100% pur sang spécial zombies c'est très
présent mené interview pinceau miguel
barcelo pour un tableau 50000 $ tout à
l'heure paris est une fête maire gère
fait le têt plus gardiennés ferrucci le
duel et dj séquelles mouthe
comment va le king dernière s'est il
encore fertilise maxi coq ou ketchup
auto interview
voici lunettes noires pour nuits
blanches
l'émission qui ne seraient ressemble à
aucune autre
c'était trop
[Musique]
vraiment
tel aux yeux
michael
ce matin
pas trop
ses dépens que ce soit je bois
c'est la soif c'est papa
je n'ai jamais fais est question
le drap
c'est fini
drafté venez
temps et le jour 2
et entassés ans
tant m
comment tu as vendu des disques optiques
leur rêve ans
dans une longue histoire
les cavaliers
je pars tous les
ma
les ir en mer mais pour m -a
avec le cinéma
vous avez gagné
imaginez
l'étranger
ghadames en france un des jo
je lis rien à la nature et les damnés
instruits
5 et 6 e
est ce qu'on a
oui
des âmes et après j'aurais moi
je
elle avait pas
bien joué
peut-être j'ai plus riches
soit 7
est-ce que tu n'es pas
trop cher le dossard
je veux pas répondre
question
avec lui
mais un terrain
là aussi
m
non
des fruits lama
ap st
mais ciel l'eau qui n'avait score on
s'est tu dis
j'ai pas d
et des maris c'est vrai mardi toujours
du livre
c'est pas les passer
je sais
on va d'abord
ces bleus
pas
pas par l'éditeur
je passais il
toi tu crois je dirais trouverai
quelqu'un
jean-louis alors bonjour
je cours à exister bleus
on a sauvé
pourquoi pourquoi pas
brigitte bardot
les indiens
c
on va dire ici ils ne passent que
drap d'or
quelque chose déjà
g
je préfère
dans
le même
j'ai beaucoup donné mauvais pour moi
passé
si c'était
fr
là je vais très content
quand j'ai vu
moi j'encourage les plus nombreux que le
jeune
jusque mois
com
on n'est plus
dans la malle
[Musique]
16 ans
m
le plus de qualité le plus le manipuler
il a plu
je fais
et tout le monde est prêt d'être
c'est arrivé
existait pas
romain teulet
un régal c'était un régal
et des pires
des commandes
[Musique]
un an plus tôt
tout s'arrête
rare et beau et
névroses et n'a jamais les projets
qu'est ce qu'un débat
des projets
je suis pas
plus que l'écart
dennis hopper le garçon que vous avez
sous les yeux et à lui tout seul un
morceau d'anthologie du rock'n'roll
mesdames messieurs
johnny thunder a les agents tonnerre ou
quand la foudre met le feu à la poudre
hier à abobo
[Musique]
de l'amour
[Applaudissements]
tu
oh
en toi
[Musique]
heureusement tu crois
heureusement tout cry c'était johnny
thunder merci qui merci titi voici
claudia philips spécialiste de montaigne
et la boétie instructive cette émission
je viens philips bonsoir
vous avez commencé à l'été 2
oui oui avec uncle bad boy est un
marchand d'or c'est d'abord été aussi la
réussite à l'avant du combien
ouais deschamps est ce que tu as lu
montaigne et la boétie
et non c'est pas lui tu sais je sais
quoi je sais c'est qu'il est
un curé à qu'ils adoraient le plaisir
dans la vie rennes ne s'est réveillé
avec des pétales de roses
sur le visage la nuit pour le plaisir de
s'endormir c'est un mot de tous qu'il
faut savoir enchaîner au en californie
ouais
j'étais venu de manta en avion c'est
cadel evans qui sait comment commandes à
trouver l'amérique et des effusions en
passant parce que je suis jamais
ces français qui donne une homonymie son
prénom c'est par un prénom c'est ben
c'est pas trop dur à porter comme un
américain de 47 ans qui sort qui
s'appelle souvenez vous de nous oui
mentonnais pouvait danser bien qu'on ait
jamais vu ça après coup droit
[Musique]
combien
encore
[Musique]
c'est de parler mais les montées
les deux centièmes je voulais danser
mais
m
elle
mon genou
nous
[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]
le même producteur que le premier
actionnaire
tu vas te poses des questions qu'il faut
mais la télévision alors maintenant je
trouve c'est des questions assez qu'on
compose en général voir maintenant je
vais te poser des questions encore plus
con si c'est possible oui oui j'ai
entendu parler des questions cons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le dîner qu'il serait le plus chez
imagine que je viens de signer comme
s'asseoir au couteau privilèges est ce
que tu peux faire et dîner avec un sourd
muet ou à 9h lebègue
c'est con hein son mulet web buzz
pourquoi je connais pas la langage pour
les we have had vertu peut être cassée
pendant que les allemands chinois est
remplacé par quelqu'un qu'il
reconnaîtrait pas la différence
alors le mot français tu parle très bien
le français le le gros mot français que
tu préfères
et est-ce que c'est con
merde ou merde cartonnerie merde
parce que merde quand je vais à mes
enfants je comprenais pas pourquoi
toujours tout le monde même dans les
matches entre chercheurs peut pas dire
ça c'était tout l effectif surtout pas
la tulipe celui que doit adopter comme
en france après les prix alors imaginons
maintenant que tu rentres chez toi un
soir tu vois ton jules au lit avec
vanessa paradis
pourquoi c'est pas possible ça s'est
fait tout à fait pression sur son
économie à la clientèle grandissante
qu'est ce que tu fais oui il faut ce
qu'il faut commencer à se méfier qu'est
ce que tu fais tous les rejoindre le lit
je la tue plus de quatre mois quatre à
bord l'espère histoire parfait c'est lui
que je suis belle
celle ci touche par avec mon agent et
passe à 3 ans qu'elle est mignonne
un régime soient obligés de faire
l'amour story j'étais un fusil sur la
tempe
tu préfères faire l'amour avec un mec
les une fille très jolie
l'accès difficile à changer jamais fait
l'amour avec une fille peut pas être le
seul effet la moitié non
c'est en californie quand même c'est pas
quelque chose à ces pays où les gens
l'espère oui la californie oui
l'amérique parce que jamais je me moi
c'est comme l'héroïne j'ai l'occasion je
souhaite pas de suite la medefi je sais
faire alors on est jeune et jolie ou
avec très léger mais je dois dire un mec
très déco même pas ce que c'est bon ça
me dégoûte à ce point la non écoute voir
mais je sais pas mais si je suis obligé
je connais si j'aime pas notre bon pour
moi avec un mec les jeux pas fermer les
yeux
tu connais benoît goldman oui je les
connais tout va qui s'était jusque là et
on imagine que tu dois partir dans un
vaisseau spatial pendant quatre ans en
apesanteur
comment faire
flotte avec sa femme en quatre ans de
quelle tu choisis
sabato n 5 quand même
goldman oui pourquoi au nom j'en à
supporter face à toi dernière question
j'allume la radio on se dit que la bombe
atomique va tomber dans cinq minutes
qu'est ce que tu fais c'est des choix
les cinq dernières minutes qui précèdent
c'est à dire tous les employés refusent
tout le monde va mourir tu à antony dans
5 minutes à la bombe commis pour son
indépendance pour toujours pas quoi mais
les causes des saints mais je pense que
je prends vraiment 20 km et dans l'ue
que je vais que la france la minute
comment l'aventuré l'amour c'est la plus
grande prière par admin le
titre
exclu les années 20 la source 80 avec et
philharmonic orchestra
on le prend lui feras tu me dises mochav
comme disait cap cana will cotton club y
avait du bruit
[Musique]
j
latin
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
et
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
et à
[Musique]
les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
tous
[Musique]
et
c'était réglé philharmonic orchestra et
leur version sonore mondiales de mini de
moocher autres spécialistes en minimes
at 9 gabriel anti portrait chinois après
lunettes noires de la semaine voici les
lunettes de la semaine photo françois
dimanche antoine de caunes on attend
rapido sur canal+ de caunes moins de
béton c'est pas qui c'est mais l'air
cool est la poulette jean-pierre ben
comme un astre qu'elles font les filles
devant kalfon
on s'y trompe pas avec le tronc pas de
bobino c'est marie-france ambiance
allen 10 sur deux corps qui joue les est
légal taris latino tout passe tout lasse
1 sauf le palace hockey
[Musique]
alors gabriel matzneff ressorte de toi
trois livres en même temps cette
camisole de flamme journal chez folio
comme le feu mais et d'aromates à la
table ronde et les moins deux saisons
chez julia et lors d'un coup trois
plaques
mais voilà mets ça sur ma des vieux
enfants mais les éditeurs passent leur
temps à dire qu'un livre good i'm on est
foutu et qu'il faut faire en fait c'est
vrai des mauvais livres vers la ville la
plupart des livres qui existent mais
quelqu'un a été créé des beaux livres
des bons libre mais assez comme le bon
vin ils sont encore meilleurs dix ans
après quinze ans maintenant tout le
monde peut les rires parce que c'est
quand même beaucoup moins cher que quand
c'est sorti j'imagine la wii non parce
qu'on est cher c'est pour moi je suis
surtout folie en espagne est certain que
ça c'est là
à la portée de toutes les bourses je me
suis intéressé à tanout is dans le
dictionnaire de jérôme garcin
dictionnaire des écrivains par semaine
et j'ai découvert dans globe
un pamphlet à petit billet dix ans qui a
fait utiliser nos débuts on devait être
puis à la fin on se retrouve 250 qui
sont les 150 autres alors qu'ils sont
les 150 autres dans ce dictionnaire deux
jours de garde ça c'est à dire que
jérôme est parti en disant vous serez
centre et puis je pense que françois
bourin est un jeune éditeur il a eu des
coups de téléphone gens qui sont dans
les maisons d'édition des gens qui sont
les prix parce qu'elle est prévue par
les écrivains sont dans des situations
littéraire soit des gens qui font comme
moi qui écris ne sont rien à part leur
plume et leur art d'écrire il y en a pas
beaucoup
la plupart de ces gens sont placés alors
je pense qu'il ya un tas de membres des
jurys littéraires qui ont dit et nous et
c est ce qui fait qu'on s'est retrouvé
comme dans le cid nous aide nous
partîmes 500 mais en arrivant au port
j'allais là où cinq ans ils ont deux
cent cinquante dont 150 bragard même sûr
en fait on aurait dû être dix fois ce
que tu fais tu dis que tu es entré en
littérature ce que tout le monde c'est
d'ailleurs par un par un essai qui
traitait du suicide et que tu finiras
suicide et amène à dire que tu as déjà
bouclé la boucle
oui j'annonce mon suicide mais
contrairement à certains de nos élus
surtout que j'ai pas avec la british
airways comme tous les ans à la roma 0 0
la suite il ya autre chose que tu dis
dans cette notice nécrologique bon que
tout le monde sait c'est que tu as
toujours préféré les filles au maire ça
ça fait partie le portefeuille ou quand
ils s'appellent les moins deux saisons
dont tout le monde le sait c'était un
programme tipa programme et que tu aimes
bien les fils à l'occasion surtout quand
j'étais très jeune j'étais beaucoup plus
sensible au genre de petit garçon mais
je te dire que plus j'ai vieilli et plus
les jeunes filles ont compris de
marseille c'est fini les petits garçons
mais tu disais toute façon sans
toutefois c'est partout garde d'honneur
en fait vous êtes que ce que tu aimais
chez les petits garçons
c'était leur féminité et que finalement
les adolescents constituent une réelle
troisième ça et c'est ça que tu dises
l'adolescence et troisième sexe beaucoup
puisque les curés tu dis toujours que tu
es pédophiles mais pas homosexuel que
c'est pas la même chose parce que les
dauphines ses mails et petits-enfants et
légendes sur la gêne pas lâché on
écouterait les grandes passions c'est en
plein ce soit prendre jusqu'à ou vanessa
comment inspire et environnement avait
14 ans et 15 ans c'est quand même peu
avant son histoire d antan imagina mais
les maternelles c'est quand même des
jeunes filles par exemple qui ont tout à
fait l'âge des mais d'avoir des amendes
ailleurs au xviie siècle il aurait déjà
été mariée
hum ça tire mais pas sadique parce
qu'ils imaginent les gens qui nous
regardent ce soir là et on dit en mai
son maximum à internat à venir vraiment
choisi d'être en mars à toi oui non avec
quelqu'un qui nous unit à la télévision
d'autres étoiles pour dire moi j'aime
bien faire l'amour avec les petites
villes ou avec des petits garçons dans
le temps c'est toujours très choquant
c'est toujours très scandaleux même au
jour d'aujourd'hui et tu sais très bien
fait de plus en plus je pense oui c'est
ça nous a plaisanté choquant parce que
nous avançons vers la vertu celle là
elle
la fin du xxème siècle sera extrêmement
banlieusarde vertueuse et est constipé
tu as dit je préfère ce qui me fait peur
c'est pas l'âge c'est la baci semant une
très belle phrase très juste
mais je crois que je pense et ça dans le
zen je fais un peu jaser dans le zen on
peut prendre position dans leurs bras je
crois que petit tabouret tenant nos
droits eh bien je crois que c'est
moralement très important je pose une
question d'attitude dans la vie il faut
et qu'on ait de l'argent quand on est
pas qu on hamm est un ils sont plusieurs
une question de rigueur de deux mondes
qui faut être frais il faut toujours
valeurs de santé de sa douche dans
l'existence
et je n'aime pas la crasse morale et la
cravache et l'agissement ton style est
très rigoureuse c'est ce qui fait sa
force et c'est pour ça qu'on peut relire
tous ces bouquins dont l'un d'entre eux
sortis en 69 l'autre en 74 et c'est très
rigoureux dans le style c'est très près
de dépouiller comme ça et c'est pour ça
que ça sur vire au bord de l'abyme je
crois qu'on peut se rapprocher dix ans
au point virgule quoi on peut se
raccrocher la langue française et est un
tel garde souvent que désespoir
quant à mort contre la folie quand tous
les excès que l on peut s'abandonner les
uns les autres de tous ordres et quand
on a la chance d'avoir cet instrument de
travail qu'à la langue française c'est
bien il faut il faut en être fier il
faut il faut en profiter en temps il
faut en jouir pleinement
on va faire un petit jeu tu connais le
portrait chinois
j'avais moins de 16 ans
[Musique]
si tu étais une injure une injure
allez vous faire c'est là même de
salaire c'est
exactement j'étais un microbe
c'est pas l'arrivisme way cet été un
poison le cyanure un suicidaire comme
moi ça c'est un collabo
3 bat et rebâtir j'admire beaucoup les
deux étendards quitte à en descendre un
des plus grands noms français du xxème
siècle un dictateur nero
pourtant tu connais bien les philippines
qui a même passé du temps j'arrivais à
tous filé dans les tribunes de madame
marcos marcos n'ait pas été interdite
alors que c'était un peu notre marque
d'un grand calomnie n est ce pas bon moi
je regrette marcos c'était un homme
extrêmement mal martin a aussi qu'il
fallait quelqu'un de germes en et marcos
avait un peu plus de branches marco
c'était un n'est pas si mauvais
que les gens qui en parlent minimale
parcouru marcos mais marcos l'indicateur
non moi je reste année en service
je dirais le vrai fils pour moi ça
serait d'abstinence ou alors on pourrait
dire l'ivrognerie parce que j'adore le
bon vin formidable un mois avant la
cigale tony giles live dans lunettes
jeta pur facile qu'elle vit tony
[Musique]
9 m
il faut
[Musique]
jusqu'à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
choi
[Musique]
c'est tout
m
star
c'est ça
beaucoup de stars
m
[Musique]
ils sont offerts
les bonnes personnes
et l'on rit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
g
mais c'est
[Applaudissements]
tél
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
ce
m
seul
[Musique]
m
merci foucault gilbert pas jean-pierre
bande de nazes championne du monde dans
la castafiore c'était tony child est
maintenant sans une ride
voici lou reed
[Musique]
d
le stade
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
voilà on
lagacé
[Musique]
boire
enfin pas
sa mort est un symbole
[Musique]
et ça
notre ami
[Musique]
les garçons
m
[Musique]
mais
enfin danone
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
temps
oui
[Musique]
assemblée
ça
ce soit
m
[Musique]
ternois soit vrai
ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
mon meilleur album déclare le méchant
loup en parlant de new york extrait de
new york exclu exclude ou darty
boulevard en attendant à lui ce que
stella la semaine prochaine merci qui
merci tu y ailles
[Musique]
c'est un agent
je n'irai pas
[Musique]
en plus
je vais te les plus
il
de l'événement
[Musique]
juniper et jamie dimon
ni soit ce que tu fais
mais cette frappe de diers campements de
roms
[Musique]
non
tel événement
conteur
2 les bleus
[Musique]
n'est ce pas
l'edhec risk and men
[Musique]
à ce manque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les jo c'est du nouveau collège et une
école
il note que j'ai assisté à des principes
[Musique]
c'est un principe il rappelé
monceau fleurs
on ne l'est plus
ah bon dès ce matin
[Musique]
à
après loulou star de loulay taux
suivants c'est au tour du petit brun du
grand bleu blind test eric serra eric
serra bonsoir c'est le triomphe qua non
soir un million de gens qui sont allés
voir le grand bleu il y en a 10 % quand
acheter la musique du film que tu as
écrite en général une bande originale de
film c'est cinquante mille albums et toi
tu en es à 500000 quoi ouais ça dépend
des bandes de g j'ai fait deux trois
musiques de films qui ont vendu à 1000
albums et puis celle là ouais c'est 700
mille dix ans quand j'ai perdu une heure
étant donné le premier compact
or en france c'est ça ouais ouais c'est
la première fois qu'un compact dépasser
les cent mille exemplaires
[Musique]
m
lui
non
alors en amérique ils n'ont pas pris ta
musique par contre qu'est ce qui s'est
passé exactement
ils ont jugé que le film était trop
français pour eux
enfin pour l'américain moyen exemple
qu'il fallait changer quelque chose et
le seul la seule chose qui était
techniquement changeable c'était la
musique
puisqu'on peut pas au dernier moment
changer un acteur ou le merrer en scène
donc aller sans changer à la musique
voilà pour écrire la musique a été
obligé de d'aller sur le tournage de
travailler avec eux ouais j'ai été
d'abord ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on est
on est partis luc besson jean reno et
moi on est parti sur un bateau pendant
deux mois pour faire de la plongée avant
même du clergé avant non j'aurais fait
très peu comme un peu comme tout le
monde et on est parti pendant deux mois
avant même que le scénario sera écrit et
on a plongé pendant deux mois pour
vraiment tous partir de la même chose et
après j'ai la balle est maintenant de 32
minutes dans 30 ans ton père était
musicien quand même c'est pas par hasard
tous à nantes j'ai commencé à jouer de
la guitare quand tu avais quand avait
cinq ans et a eu la première grattant 11
ans première guitare électrique en ont
besoin est
j'ai jamais voulu apprendre vraiment la
musique mon père mais essayer de me
faire enfin nous pousser à apprendre la
musique je peux lui donnons et et il a
eu l'intelligence de ne pas me forcer
c'est à dire il a jamais un système qui
fait que la musique ça tout ça m'a
toujours paru quelque chose de
de vraiment agréable à 100% j'ai jamais
vue de ma jamais forcer à faire quoi que
ce soit ça a toujours été vraiment la
chose idéale pour entendu parler du
blind test de lunettes noires oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
anas de la guitare quand appris que des
guitar hero soir
[Musique]
a reconnu ouais c'est qui c'est jimmy
hendrix ben brik c'est quand même le
mais qui est vraiment révolutionnaire et
guitare donc tout le monde connaît sous
mon père c'est sûr
[Musique]
e
c'est le plein
on avait parlé alors c'est une orangerie
suivi ouais c'est ça ouais ouais on
devrait les qui joue je sais que le
grossiste a créé
[Applaudissements]
lee
moi je sais pas qui je crée une piste
je te donne à une piste spencer davis
group
[Musique]
j'savais pas bien j'aime faire huer
pour lui j'ai fait jeff beck
oh ça c'est un kit à la part d'un accord
je propose qu'on me une chorale
ah ouais j'ai fait ce qui est une de mes
idoles touareg
je connaissais pas ça ce n'était pas
dûment talus mais quand il va pas jusque
là ça c'est george benson on broadway
ça devrait être fait d'ici
[Musique]
et nous
[Applaudissements]
m
il
aucune idée mam
aucune idée
non
français ça
m
mais on n'entend rien mais plus fort
c'est ma demande
magma pas jouer avec leur statut après
qu'en terme à ma maison
ouais enfin j'ai fait une fois une
séance et fréquenté un peu magma ce pour
moi ça aurait dû être un des plus grand
droit le monde
c'est christian lambert c'est un génie
de taille
tu trouves pas ça c'est grave
[Musique]
jacques myard majorité tout lander
santana ouais
[Musique]
à celle des panneaux
je
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle masque sans morceaux en solo franco
battiato namadi extrait de son 17e 33
physionomie cas
qui vivra verra qui a bu boira quai
c'est assez rare et ses terres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
cannon
corrida
[Musique]
mais
le nez bien
non
tout y est
le civil temps
taïg khris ou
des jeunes
quand
minka
labbadia clé cusco nous
à trouver l'amour
la drogue
[Musique]
la ville de l'astreinte
sitôt
tous à l'école lapierre
la 17ème dérivés
brody de la mi temps
m
l'assaut
[Musique]
coc
première option serait la gamme if
design team moto est menée tôt
[Musique]
le kit à
non
il vient d'arriver
quelques-uns
hospital
pas si fort
même si m
mais surtout
[Musique]
san juan charlie
oh
ils sont 1
à
[Applaudissements]
yj
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était franck kom attia de temps elle
son fameux saut violoniste à llano pour
louis blériot secrétaire général des
programmes centaine de ces abcès dan
en tout cas c'est louis baillot bonsoir
sacré paul scherrer bon alors c'est très
marrant ce bouquin parce que quand on
lit la quatrième de couverture
quand on commence le livre tout ça c'est
un ton un peu près vers bords de marne
marcel aymé gentillet retour ni la
quatrième de couverture pareil et puis
quand on rentre dans le livre on
s'aperçoit que ça traite d'un problème
grave
cette traite de l'euthanasie alors
pourquoi cette discrétion au niveau du
titre pourquoi ce discrétion au niveau
de la quatrième de couverture
et pourquoi en avoir fait une histoire
vraiment pourquoi ne pas avoir fait un
essai finalement
d'abord ça traîne pas complètement de
l'euthanasie ça en parle mais ça parle
surtout du sens de la vie
au moment où on arrive à la retraite
oui on a envie de savoir ce comment t'es
tu es dernières années et ce que veut
dire le livre c'est que si on vit bien
sa vie en vie bien sa mort tu me fraudin
nouveaux droits de l'homme qui est le
droit de finir en beauté et tudyk
appartement on étouffe une vie dans
l'oeuvre quand on quand on se fait
avorter ou quand on accepte l'avortement
il n'y a pas de raison qu'on n'accepte
pas la même chose drame à interrompre la
vie au départ qui n'interrompt pas la
fin parce qu'à la fin elle a vécu
tandis qu'au début je sais bien que ça
pose des problèmes si les problèmes
sociaux c'est pas des prêts moreau alors
qu'on vienne pas me dire qu'à la fin de
la vie est grave de poser cette question
là alors qu'on se pose pas pour le début
de la vie ça me paraît paradoxal
est ce que je veux dire c'est que nous
qui sommes des gaulois d'arriver enfin
je présume que tu en es moi je suis tout
que le mât du suspens m'enfin faut pas
oublier que les gaulois c'était des gens
qui hésitent ai pas donné la mort et
notamment quand l'honneur était en jeu
est ce que je veux dire aujourd'hui
c'est que
je ne prêche pas le suicide est ce que
je veux dire c'est que la vraie dignité
d'un homme
ce serait comme l'indien qui dit yvon ma
vie est finie montre sur la montagne et
il s'endort pour l'éternité
car il sait qu'après sa vie sera plus
riche que celle qu'il a vécue sur le sol
de ses ancêtres
alors oui est-ce que tu as entendu
parler de l'interview à peine dame
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu préfères en tant que
capitaine
voilà c'est vrai parce que je venais à
être un endroit est-ce que tu détestes
fait parlant de chez toi ce que tu
détestes centaines de l'avenue montaigne
je dire en quoi est-ce que l'endroit est
formidable ouais mais alors lui même
ressemble à un hôpital
quelle est la meilleure idée que tu as
eue depuis que certaines de ces
difficile à dire parce que
j'aurais l'air de me vanter comme vrai
j'aime bien le téléthon c'est pas une
idée de moi mais c'est moi qui les
promus voilà j'aime bien le drapeau de
blanc c'est pas une idée de moi mais
c'est moi qui ai eu l'idée l'échelle
régionale à 19h30 c'est pas une mauvaise
idée ça par exemple
c'est une idée risquèrent ouais mais
c'est pas une mauvaise idée au moins en
tête de rat un programme en face de la
roue de la fortune
oui et puis en plus on donnera aux
français une soirée plus agréable c'est
à dire que si tu fais le journal à 19h30
à 20h tu peux mettre le film mais voilà
et puis à 22 heures tu tu peux mais
parmi ses adhérents très les français
donc il faut le faire avec une
délicatesse si on fait un jour qu'elle
est la plus mauvaise idée que j'ai eue
depuis que l'antenne de ces moments des
questions tout ça parce que c'est pas
longtemps si l'interview fan d'art la
plus mauvaise idée j'ai vraiment un truc
que tu as dis quand même jour j'ai eu
cette idée c'est d'accepter d'être
secrétaire
c'est pas les sitcoms à 19h30 dans la
pourquoi tu me dis ça mais je te dis ça
je sais pas moi cette interview je me
pose des questions je répondre à cette
question
ça va être long j'essaie de le faire et
à dire s'il connaît marc et sophie ont
marqué ces situations c'est sur la
chaîne concurrente
c'est nul ouais à côté nos sites comme
c'est grandiose
ouais tu marques est sortie ça marche
très bien alors que nos sites comme
marche pas bien pas une raison très
simple c'est que les programmes qui sont
avant et qui se répandent pas de nous
qui sont les actualités régionales les
français ont pris l'habitude d'aller les
voir sur fr3 et plus chez nous si bien
que quand arrivent les sites comme il
n'y a pas beaucoup de français qui sont
allés devant leur poste ce que tu
préfères dans la vie c'est quoi
[Musique]
je vais te dire que tu vas pas me croire
ici les moutons c'est aller chez moi
dans la campagne je vous fais du bourg
construire ma bergerie
mais bâtiment elle travaillait que mes
mains et puis le reste du temps écrire
et puis le reste de la semaine allait à
la télé parce que tu déteste le plus
dans la vie lui qui tel fichier de tuff
gong
c'est pas possible
la bagnole est ce que tu préfères en toi
à moi en toi louis blériot ce que tu
préfères ce qui te sens bête de près le
plus préférable que j'aime la vie ouais
et je m'aime bien parce que j'aime la
chaleur alors est ce que c'est parce que
c'est ça fait un privilège formidable ce
que tu détestes en toi mon outrecuidant
il m'arrive de penser qu'un accent
qu'ont ces tableaux c'est du pèze
interview pinceau armes égales barcelone
j'ai 31 ans et tu es devenu en quelques
années une des plus grosses cotes de la
peinture internationale
mais
puis bien plus important que la movida
de mais tu fais partie d'une génération
d'espagnol fin de peintres espagnols qui
ont dépassé l'après franquisme c'est à
dire que tu n'es plus enfermer dans
mirow dans le nationalisme catalan dans
le repli sur soi c'était tout va
beaucoup plus loin que ça j'espère oui
mais quand même ils ont tous à cet
instrument important pour moi ces
mélodies aussi l'habitat justement dans
majeur qui espérons le
alors j'ai eu la chance parce que ta
mère était peinte et quand j'étais tout
petit on t'a mis un pinceau dans les
mains très très jeune chez étudie j'ai
su très jeune qui était sésame jeux
précités en forme c'est de me dire qu'il
me tarde d'être acquise en coin ouais
c'est une façon de faire rester trop
mais c'est quelque chose je suis un
agent quelqu'un j'étais triste
il va être beaucoup de prendre brenner
comme salle jean monnet qui sortait
dimanche c'est vraiment trop étrange ils
apprendraient penseurs comme un géant
sur la familiarité avec les moyens
d'être étant je pense que c'est très
important aussi de savoir la première
exposition c'était à palma oui dès lors
que je vais me tuer piller petites
boîtes dans lesquelles tu avais enfermés
derrière un tueur et puis des matières
organiques s'élèverait nature morte amy
tu commences était venue cette idée
quand même parce que c'est bizarre quand
on demande quel âge tu avais quand tu as
fait ça à 17 ans tu faisais ça c'est à
dire j'ai commencé à me sentir les deux
matériaux organiques pour faire un peu
sort de la world music is up
pour provoquer une sorte de
vieillissement des appétits alors je
vais me ranger vos deux avions dash et
sur ce coup je vous ai fait une série de
reports ferait presque avec de la viande
de matériaux organiques qui
pourrissaient s'était enfermé avec un
verre c'est vrai mais trop noir pour le
ct les autres portraits qui alors je
viens d'ici en vitesse fini en trois
jours j'ai passé d'avoir 17 ans je
n'aurai 115 consomme un quart du monde
steve marino qui m'a pris pas moins d
oui la dérive des continents
mais bien sûr c'était avec de la viande
sur un gros risque de c'était
nos frais beaucoup voyagé un peu comme
les étudiants du moyen-âge c'est à dire
que quand tu lisais et pessoa tu partais
à lisbonne quand tu voulais étudier
caravage tu partais anac ensuite est
venue à paris pendant de longues années
pour étudier le louvre et puis les
pattes alors pour ça c'est un appui j'ai
trouvé travail c'est pour ça que c'est
comme ça que ça s'est passé là tu
rentres du mali qui était allé faire au
mali budgétaires pendant à paris pendant
4,58 à new york et j'en avais un peu
marre ou pousser sur le circuit pour un
moment je les galeries tous à 7,7 énervé
c'est castelli faut le dire comme c'est
castelli à new york c'est lambert à
paris c'est pas les plus mauvais c'est
pour ça mais j'ai bien pensé ok ce
curseur à tourner dans le même sens
c'est à dire que c'est chaque année des
espoirs avec quelques points importants
aussi leur nid c'est plus rien
il s'était énervé ça j'avais pas vue
l'autre sur l'or physique terrible
projet comme ça martine aubry mais la
peinture elle sèche vite au mali quand
même comment tu faisais cgd trouver 120
technique un prêt spécial pour
travailler dans une autre façon aussi
parce qu'elle est ado énorme comme ça
dans de petites maisons de maurice était
presque sais pas je me sentais pas
capable de faire deux saisons ces deux
formats j'ai trouvé une façon longueur
chaque tableau a vécu cette influence
est parti juste n'importe où toute la
grande baroque grand père c'est lui qui
t'a le plus influencé non mais je
regarde plusieurs beaux costards
cravates commencer quelque chose très
importante des français je regardais
beaucoup ses traditions qui va de
poussan le shard à magny cours mais oui
j'ai copié beaucoup
c'est pareil mais j'ai fais pas trop
attention c'est égal risque il dit ça si
je prends ton temps ça s'est même pas
très amusant 7 points communs tombeau
par un tableau bras sa dernière menaçait
beaucoup c'est à dire qu'entre juillet
et descend pas les divers rites
aborigènes et détruit presque augmenté
alors se faire seppuku t'écoute quoi
quand tu pas pardon tu écoutes quelle
musique quand tu parles
est-ce que tu écoute pas mais la radio
via n'importe quoi je la t'écoute pas
spécialement un groupe ou une musique
non après quand je ne fais pas appel
quand j'écoutais spécialement de
certaines choses mais s'il devait rester
de toi une définition dans le
dictionnaire de la peinture dorée que ça
soit quoi en une ligne
c'est dur artiste peintre c'est tout
je crois que oui c'est plutôt drôle
comme ça une complication
ça sert à quoi la peinture anti ça sert
à passer détendre
puis ça doit peut-être aux autres se
serrent préparent à intervenir mais je
crois que c'est une princesse en forme
de tasse étant en cours de rock et funk
avec darou ce mois ci lazzaro ex un
style ex folk devenu chef de boucherie
productions françois hadji-lazaro 10
army et son poteau qui est là riton
mitsou quand vous interprète rigal
georges ulmer version carnivores on
adore exclu lui
comme ça
bigard la scène
comme les succès
[Musique]
ce mois ci
visage comme un pou sensationnel
mais langage comme à la tour de babel
et
m
[Musique]
il faut dire qu'ils ont discrètement
je
pierre saby
[Musique]
on
genou
[Musique]
et
15h15
voici un miracle que monsieur cinéma du
rock'n'roll avec françois hadji-lazaro
héritons mitsouko tous les deux de
boucherie productions c'est un spécial
boucherie productions ce soir ça veut
dire que quel que soit le candidat qui
gagne boucherie productions a gagné tu
es d'accord tu en avais dit comme
d'habitude alors boucherie productions
c'est quoi ces les garçons bouchers
d'abord blessé le garçon boucher c'est
los carayos et la mano negra ses
filiales
[Musique]
c'est ton vrai nom françois dieu hasard
ou non voyons c'est françoise hardy
d'accord ben justement alors on va
commencer avec toi on va commencer avec
les pseudos quel est le vrai nom paquet
quel est le nom qu'a pris le garçon qui
s'appelait reginald white n'était pas le
gardien de but de l'équipe de manchester
dans la foulée il est drôle ça peut
avancer c'est un chanteur anglais qui
adore la tandja ouais les gars ont pu
s'appeler 2 klahn patrick mc manus il se
fait appeler comme je sais aucune idée
mais si il a pris le nom d'une superstar
du rock et il a pris le son nom de
famille il a choisi un comics américains
hubert-félix nord des années 50 est
resté loin
[Applaudissements]
tu vas alors concernés césar mm bon on
va prendre qui ont appelé les grilles
vers twins ces deux groupes à risque ont
fait un look qui a eu un succès
incroyable c'est trop facile
les crimes et retweets c'est qui
sa part a beau avoir les jetons ouais
c'est un rapport avec l'âge
alors c'est facile maintenant tu sais
que c'est un héros là je pense
les haut-rhinois non c'est les rolling
stones mais c'est lesquels chez les
stones affaiblissent les charges
et ben voilà on l'applaudît alors vous
pensé à toi on est toujours dans l'est
sûrement quel est celui qu'on appelait
mr dame ait aucune idée soit mais oui
j'ai qui s'est pas de ce monde mais
ouais ben ali dont on comprend pourquoi
c'est lui le chef d'antenne bas et en
suisse il existe toujours même s'ils en
taule à la james bond pas franchement
bon ballon à faire la rue alors à faire
la rue g dire une chanson tu vas me dire
qu'elle est telle qu'elle est et les
interprètes
or dead end street de 906 la fin des 60
faire et soissons ouais
les kings ouais aulas président était
d'accord et j'ai fait des études à
thoiry ton 461 je te le font en français
ocean's boulevard des grands guitaristes
devant l'éternel le plus grand et qui
sourit lui succéder à les réprimer ces
classes de préparer un bon alors à toi
maintenant françois les chansons qui ont
été censurés c'est toujours un peu
limite quand même les chansons qui ont
été censurés la chanson de francky gosse
tout hollywood qui s'appelle relax a été
censurée pour quelle raison un ton avis
se bat vas-y pour homosexualité
bravo mon petit tu prends la sienne la
chanson a day in the life des beatles a
été a eu des problèmes avec la censure
pour quelles raisons ouais pour l'asian
isme non c'est juste bon pour la drogue
day in the life françois de la dronne
suis pas si l'on prenait mais la chanson
évoqué le problème en tous les cas tu
savais pas
on t'a vu tu roules tu monte doucement
là on va faire les prisons maintenant
pour toi une chanson d'elvis 158 qui
parle de prison j'ai la drogue
ah ben voilà une chanson dali des ans 64
qui parle de prison aussi le pénitencier
oh la la la la
super talent ça c'est vraiment mais le
plus difficile tpr et françois bon les
mecs qu'on fait qu'un succès dans leur
vie
baby come back 1967 les beatles mais
quoi
ecall c'est ça ouais ouais ouais
j'espère
c'est on associe il est pas mal alors à
toi là dans fire 1968
arthur mans c'est lui qui les applaudit
[Musique]
day clubbing sylvain bergère dimanche
après-midi guèye au prince avec marc of
l uci numéro top 50 des dj spaghetti
c'est à paris dit qu'il retrouve ses
tifosi le kiki au passage saluant la
nouvelle formule de starfix pour starfix
une idée fixe faire un bon magazine de
cinéma
si vous avez les seins qui tombent fait
toujours à faire le nez ça détourne
l'attention c'est un conseil de pierre
desproges nouvel an chinois la mutu
organisée par les viêt à paris l'amicale
et sud-est asie le journal 1988 année du
dragon tout est beau 1989 année du
serpent c'est moins craquant chaque
année la fête du têt c'est le grand
balayage de printemps chasse aux
fantômes avec des pétards on les
comprend
on passe aux news dimanche 19 février
grégory à isaac ce concert reggae à
l'elysée montmartre
lundi 20 janvier kitaro le pape japonais
du nuage hôtel p2 jaser en plein
changement de lune
bon courage mesdames messieurs
toujours à l'elysée montmartre lundi 20
les whalers cool and the gagne à bercy
lundi matin
[Musique]
l'hiver à paris vous ennuie paraît en
plus chaud largué vous en plein
pacifique sur l'île ditty forêts
tropicales lagon turquoise it is et
extra terrestre
vous n'avez pas assez froid à court et
au groenland direction en masse à l'udc
en jour de traîneaux et 10 nuits sous la
tente
si la neige vous est ce que vous savez
que c'est en 1969 que le cinéaste e
nigérien oumarou ganda réalise kaba
skarabot on aurait un peu trop tendance
à l'oublier heureusement il ya des
proches pour nous le rappeler
soit soit soirée acide aux étoiles syrie
gants dj annie rempile le samedi soir
allez-y tout de suite
la vie est bien trop courte pour
s'endormir prises ne sombraient pas dans
le cocooning puis sautez dans le
myhtique la vigne c'était lunettes
noires pour nuit blanche le magazine pas
comme les autres qui zappe tout seul
mais là messieurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
nous verrons
courroye
bah
ab
moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous verrons
[Musique]
oui
bah
le
moi
wade
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous y mettez un
peu de bleu